san francisco 49ers at five and six
trying to make an unexpected run of the
postseason they will continue
their season playing their home games in
arizona
practicing on the grass fields outside
of state farm stadium
and there are other coaches who envy
this gig that
kyle shanahan has because there are
other coaches who wish
they could create a de facto bubble
that's what the
49ers have to the point where it's work
and it's straight to the hotel room
here's kyle shanahan talking about his
concerns that
players may feel disconnected from the
world and isolated
and he's concerned about the mental
health of some of his players here he is
from yesterday
i just tried to tell everyone no matter
what when someone has a problem whatever
it is there's no problem too big or too
small
and a lot of guys keep that stuff
internally um but you know i met with a
bunch of the players and i grabbed about
20 of them last night and just
told them to look out for that stuff and
make sure that whether they come to me
a position coach we have lots of people
here who aren't coaches or players who
can help people
um so it's just understanding that it's
human nature some stuff's going to come
up
over the next three weeks and no one
ignore it just always bring it to
someone's attention because
the worst thing you could be in these
situations is feel kind of alone on an
island and
we've got a big group going through it
so we can rally together and make sure
we help each other through it
and that's a great point he added that
he talked to about 20 players and told
them please keep an eye on your
teammates if anyone is struggling with
the isolation let's talk about it let's
be aware of it let's deal with it and
peter
when i hear him speak and i think about
what everyone is going through
you know we're all frustrated we're all
upset and maybe the ebron comments maybe
the sarcastic remark made by ben
rothersberger it's just a way of coping
so you know i don't know that a lot of
these complaints that are made really
are
you know serious back to the wall type
of i hate this
and this isn't right this isn't fair
sometimes it's just what you do
to get through a day when you feel like
everything sucks
look the 49ers are a great example of of
a team that
you know i don't know how they're going
to end up mike i really don't
but you know they are quite literally
getting on their buses to go to the
airport on saturday
and they start seeing tweets from the
county of santa clara
that all of a sudden when they get back
home they're going to have to leave
because they're going to be orphans
they're not going to be allowed to play
or practice
at their home facility so that's a fine
how do you do you get on the plane
you go to the rams in a game that you're
a significant underdog and somehow some
way
you find a way to win that game against
the rams a huge game
that all of a sudden makes you five and
six and keeps you
in the muddled playoff hunt for the
sixth or seventh seed in the in the nfc
and what is interesting to me
when they came home and then started
figuring out what they were gonna do
they don't know whether they're going to
san diego they don't know whether
they're going to
oakland they don't know where they're
going and so
they picked glendale arizona
and mike you know what they have done in
glendale they basically
have become the arizona cardinals
in training camp staying at the
cardinals training camp hotel
taking over all of their meeting space
and indoor con it's an indoor convention
center basically
taking over all that space yesterday
when i talked to people there
they were building a weight room you
know
in that space so that guys this week
could you know get focused and get going
they got the buffalo bills coming in on
monday
and so the other interesting thing for
the
for for everyone to know about this
because this
isn't like just going to an away game
you you as a if you're a player for the
49ers
your family can come to arizona
and your family can uh stay somewhere
nearby and you can visit them
now there's going to be i'm sure some
strict rules about that
but this isn't a situation where they
have to stay penned up
in their hotel rooms and so that's going
to be a tricky little scenario
for kyle shanahan to manage over the
next three weeks
yeah the families can basically get an
airbnb type of a thing and
the player will commute back and forth
just as if he were at home which does
puncture that bubble a little bit
shanahan said yesterday they're going to
try to not be part of the city while
they're there
and my guess is that he's hoping that a
maximum number of guys end up just
seeing it through the next five weeks
stay in the hotel
be away from the community and reduce
the potential for catching the virus
again there are other coaches who are
looking at this saying
it's a pretty good gig if you can get it
because i no longer have to worry about
my guys going at home every night and
coming back
potentially positive for covet 19 any
given day
and then all of the dominoes that fall
because of that now
i'm told the nfl players association did
not give the nfl or the 49ers a hard
time about this
even though the 49ers are taking the
players
out of their normal routine out of their
homes
away from their families and moving them
to arizona for five weeks there's an
acknowledgement that certain things just
have to be done and
they make sure that it's done in a way
that is safe for the players and again
from a virus standpoint it is safer for
the players
now one of the practical considerations
peter that i'm glad you mentioned
the 49ers behaving essentially like the
cardinals at training camp one big
difference
they're not using the the field at state
farm stadium to practice on the
cardinals use that field extensively and
there are times early in the season
where it looks rough
but they're going to be playing six
games on that field now
in roughly a four-week window so i'm
hoping that the grounds crew there
does everything they can to make sure
the field doesn't get torn up and become
a safety hazard
for the players when you're doubling
essentially the workload that that
field's going to have and some may say
oh that's no big deal no there are some
bad fields in the nfl
and one of the reasons fields get bad is
through overuse so i'm hoping they have
a plan in place
to ensure that there's an appropriate
playing surface for everyone that's
going to be on there for the rest of the
season
mike the other the other interesting
part of this story
that people might not realize is that so
the 49ers have been told by the county
of santa clara
basically we are not allowing any group
activities or athletic events
until at least december 21 we will
reconsider
our decision based on the spread
and and how many people are getting
covered in our county
by december 21 so theoretically
it's possible if they call off the ban
the the the 49ers could come home
on december 21 or 22.
they would have to turn around three or
four days later
fly on christmas afternoon december 25
to play in arizona
on december 26th so this
is one of the all-time weird
odd schedules and also not just
schedules because
that's still uncertain it's just
totally one of the weirdest scenarios
that a team has ever had to play
through and keep in mind this is the
team that started the season
uh playing in new jersey against the
jets
going to the greenbrier in west virginia
for the week
coming back to new jersey playing the
giants and by the end of that eight days
half their team was was hurt and gone
for the year
and i'm exaggerating but this
has been a bizarre just weird year for
the 49ers and i'll tell you if somehow
they end up making the playoffs i mean
i'm not saying vote kyle shanahan coach
of the year for
keeping this together but oh my god give
that team some sort of award for
figuring out how to make all this work
and they're going to be ready to make
some noise in the postseason if they get
there after everything they've been
through and one quick note on santa
clara there has been an awkward and ugly
political dynamic between santa clara
and the 49ers ever since the 49ers moved
into levi's stadium
and there's been some barbs traded back
and forth this week i'm going to be
writing
something about it after the show today
but but that's part of it too
and you know i'm i'm cynical about
everything so let me go ahead and say at
some level it's hard not to wonder
whether this order in santa clara was
crafted in part to stick it to the 49ers
because it wouldn't surprise me if there
was some truth to that
all right the possibility of a bubble
peter something you mentioned at the top
of the show
mike tarico at halftime of the raven
steelers game
interviewed commissioner roger goodell
here's what he had to say on wednesday
about
the possibility of a bubble in the
postseason
bubbles for the regular season seem
tough to pull off have you started
thinking about bubbles for the
postseason mike our issue
on on bubbles listen the way it's
perceived i think
in the general public is that um
not something we would do because we
believe that our protocols are working
we would consider further isolations to
reduce the risk
for all of our personnel so that they're
not exposed to the virus and bring it
into the facilities or to the club
peter i've got a very simple assessment
of the situation and i've mentioned it
from time to time and i don't know that
it's getting much traction but at the
end of the day this
is a collective bargaining stare down
between the league and the union the
league doesn't want to go to the union
and say we want all the players to be
confined to a hotel because the union
will say
no no we're not doing it unless you give
us something because that's how
collective bargaining works and anytime
the union asks the nfl for something
the nfl doesn't say you know that's a
good idea that's a win-win we'll go
ahead and do it they say
we want something because you want
something and as a result
they're engaged in this stare down and
they'll come up with a word salad from
time to time to justify it but i believe
that's the heart of it
the league doesn't want to ask because
the league knows if it
asks it's gonna have to give something
to the union that doesn't currently owe
the union
makes a lot of sense mike uh and and at
the end of the day
the only way in my opinion that
this is going to be forced quite
honestly
is if one team suffers maybe even a
playoff team
suffers a significant outbreak that
causes them to miss multiple weeks
you know because then the league can say
both publicly
and to the union look we cannot risk
this happening in january
we just can't we can't delay the
playoffs for two weeks
while we're waiting for team x the third
seed in the afc
to get healthy and from the union's
perspective it's a simple analysis
because people will say well and i've
said it before earlier this year hey
union you just need to volunteer to do
this
the union looks out and says well
they're still getting the games in until
games are lost
it's not a relevant conversation i'd
like to think that folks would be
committed to doing the right thing for
the sport
before games have to be lost to get
people to wake up and say gee maybe we
should have home market bubbles that's
just not the way
this specific brand of sausage is going
to be made they are going to continue
to engage in this stare down hope they
can get through the season
and peter here's what i think is going
to happen in the postseason because i've
talked to some coaches about this
there's a belief that you won't need
mandatory bubbles in the postseason
that all the teams that are still alive
through the leadership exerted
and the pressure applied by their
leaders
in the locker room quarterbacks
defensive leaders etc
they're all going to volunteer to stay
in the hotel so you never have to make
it mandatory
you know that's what the saints proved
was the smart way to go in the month of
august they had about 135
of 168 i think people um
either close contacts with players or
players
stay in the lowe's hotel in new orleans
they closed off the hotel except to the
saints
and so to me especially
in an environment that we're in right
now mike where business
is zero you know either travel and
tourism or just
travel in many of these cities you can
find a hotel
empty out the hotel for whatever eight
days
or however long it's got to be and then
maybe extend it to 14 days if the team
wins
and you have to come back and that is
the smartest way to go
because it allows you i've also
heard the discussion mike that you know
if players go home at least they're
apart
from everybody on their team it's not
like everybody is together
all the time and you're going to have
contact with people on the team
with the risk of spreading it no what is
going to happen is that because
players all have and people all have
single rooms
and they're all doing you know the 49ers
even though they're down in arizona and
they're together
they're doing all of their learning
virtually
sitting in their room you know just like
teams are doing
all over the league right now juju smith
shuster told me
a couple of weeks ago that you know he
basically
used to get up and get and you know get
up at seven o'clock he's out of his
his home at 7 45 and he's not home till
after three
well now he stays home until 11
because he's got all his meetings in the
morning
uh you know by video conference he gets
in his car he drives
to to uh the steelers facility
does his practice and then just goes
home
and so that is the way it is like with
all these teams now so
to me i really think that the bubble is
a profitable way to go
it's a smart way to go but it's going to
take
in my opinion a quasi disaster for the
nfl to get there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports